en este problema nos dicen gráfica el
punto 7 10 muy bien tenemos que recordar
que la primera coordenada corresponde al
eje x es decir que tanto nos movemos
horizontalmente como aquí hay un 7
tenemos que movernos 7 unidades a la
derecha ahí van 7 unidades a la derecha
y la segunda coordenada este 10 indica
que tanto nos tenemos que mover
verticalmente es decir sobre el eje y
como aquí hay un 10 entonces debemos de
movernos hasta 10 y de esta forma
llegamos al punto 7 10 también pudimos
haberlo hecho al revés primero haber
visto este 10 y decir ah nos movemos 10
hacia arriba porque es la coordenada y
entonces el punto hubiera empezado aquí
y nos movíamos hasta acá hasta el punto
10 y luego nos movíamos horizontalmente
7 unidades a la derecha 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
podría ser tentador ver este 10 y
moverse 10 a la derecha y luego ver el 7
y moverse 7 hacia arriba pero entonces
ahí estarías mezclando los números y
llegarías a este punto que no es el
correcto entonces lo más importante
recordar que la primera entrada
corresponde a movimiento horizontal
sobre el eje x y la segunda corresponde
a movimiento vertical sobre el eje y
vamos a hacer algunos más eso estuvo
bien vamos a este gráfica el punto 75
muy bien misma idea
este 7 es que nos movamos 7 unidades a
la derecha y este 5 es que nos movamos 5
unidades hacia arriba 1 2 3 4 5 lo
pudimos haber hecho al revés 5 hacia
arriba 7 a la derecha y hubiéramos
llegado al mismo punto vale le picamos
aquí excelente vamos a hacer uno más
gráfica el punto 8 10
bueno pues tenemos que movernos 8
unidades a la derecha 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
unidades a la derecha
y 10 unidades hacia arriba entonces
llegaríamos a este punto de acá sale
entonces recuerda para resolver estos
problemas la primera entrada nos dice
que tanto nos movemos horizontalmente a
la derecha y la segunda nos dice que
tanto nos movemos hacia arriba o hacia
abajo si es positiva es hacia arriba
vale bueno